>> THE SENATOR OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, WE PUT FORTH
$36 MILLION TO FIND A VACCINE
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL TO FIND OUT
BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
THEY TURN DOWN BUREAUCRATIC
BARRIERS TO PAVE THE WAY.
>> OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
PUSHING TO FIND A CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE.
THE PRESIDENT PREDICTING THERE
COULD BE A BREAKTHROUGH BY THE
END OF THE YEAR.
KRISTIN FISHER IS LIVE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> OVER THE WEEKEND
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT HE
BELIEVES THE UNITED STATES WILL
HAVE A THERAPEUTIC AND OUTBOARD
VACCINE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS LONG
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
THE PERSON IN CHARGE OF THE
AGENCY IS ESSENTIALLY THE PERSON
THAT WOULD APPROVE THIS VACCINE.
DR. STEPHEN HAWN.
HE SAID IT’S VERY DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO PUT A TIMELINE
ON IT.
>> I CAN’T PREDICT WHEN A
VACCINE WILL BE AVAILABLE.
OUR SOLEMN PROMISE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS THAT WE WILL
MAKE A DECISION ON THE DATA AND
SCIENCE OF THE VACCINE WITH
RESPECT TO THE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS VACCINE.
>> DR. HAHN WAS ASKED TO MAKE
ANOTHER CLAIM OVER THE WEEKEND
THAT 99% OF CORONAVIRUS CASES
ARE HARMLESS.
DR. HAHN DECLINED TO DO SO BUT
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
DID THIS MORNING.
>> I DON’T EVEN KNOW THAT IT’S A
GENERALIZATION.
WITH THE AMOUNT OF TESTING THAT
WE HAVE COME THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE ARE SAFE FROM THIS.
>> HAS A NUMBER OF CORONAVIRUS
CASES CONTINUES TO SPIKE, THE
RACE FOR THE VACCINE HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY URGENT.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS BEEN LOOKING
TO EXPEDITE A VACCINE UNDER
OPERATION WARP SPEED BUT DESPITE
THAT EFFORT DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
SAYS IT WILL BE EARLY WINTER AT
THE EARLIEST BEFORE IT IS KNOWN
IF ANY VACCINES CURRENTLY IN
DEVELOPMENT ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
THIS MORNING CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS ALSO SAID THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL LIKELY BE
ANNOUNCING SEVERAL EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THIS WEEK ON IMMIGRATION,
MANUFACTURING DRUGS,
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES AND
CHINA.
HE SAYS THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
CONGRESS WILL TAKE THIS LONG
BREAK OVER JULY AND THEN IT IS
UP TO PRESIDENT TRUMP TO FIX